ich habe schon als kleines mädchen davon
geträumt mein eigenes spiel zu
entwickeln und das mit meinen freunden
zu teilen
wer hätte denn keine lust drauf seine
eigene welt zu kreieren und tausende
leute damit zu begeistern diese woche
versuche ich meine eigene app ohne
programmierkenntnisse in die app stores
zu bringen und damit geld zu verdienen
ich rede gar nicht lange um den heißen
brei herum wir brauchen den namen
brauchen grafiken brauchen animation
geschmust programmiert was ich nicht
kann müssen eigene sounds aufnehmen wir
brauchen den soundtrack wir brauchen
inhalte und strategien darüber wie wir
leute dazu kriegen in app käufe zu
tätigen
wir wollen auch wissen diesen geldern
mit so einer app bewegen kann und dafür
brauchen wir erstmal ne idee dieses
video wird unterstützt von meinem
eigenen schnittkurs mit dem jeder in
wenigen stunden alles lernen was man
braucht für youtube urlaubs und
musikvideos link in der beschreibung
okay was mach ich hätte bock auf was
nostalgisches ja so was ich bin genau so
was halt richtig viel charme das liegt
alles an recht richtig geile farben ich
falle dieses thema okay das machen wir
und ich hab doch auch bloß aber wie
bringt man die maus ins spiel
okay ich hab sie kombinieren einfach was
geiles von drei gänge sind zwar super
mario world absoluter klassiker chad
mcknight richtig cooles spiel über die
man einfach endlos münzen einsammeln und
hindernissen ausweicht und rpg elementen
wie aus der romandie kunde fähigkeiten
den feuerball und mais blitz wenn die
nuss drin sind ist man selber dann
wahrscheinlich ein höhlenmensch und
kämpft gegen diesen dinos klingt
eigentlich ganz cool also ich hätte lust
hoffen
das grundkonzept steht jetzt geht es an
die umsetzung ich mache mir eine liste
mit allen objekten die ich brauche und
fange an mit den grafiken im vordergrund
stehen die dinos damit ich die
proportion richtig bekomme packe ich
eine gruppe vorlage in den hintergrund
und zeichnen darauf los
der ist von echten gekürzt er ist schon
echt süß oder wenn erster diener ist ein
stiko saures und der zweite wir ein
triceratops ich gehe in diesem pixel als
echt auf gerade dadurch dass man durch
die wenigen pixeln limitiert ist muss
die kreativität deutlich gesteigert
werden ähnlich wie bei minecraft mit den
blöcken also um es dann bin ich auch
stolz drauf ich bin jetzt richtig hübsch
geworden ich glaube ich teile das dass
man aus und davon mit euch um zu sehen
was ihr davon wenn ihr auch schon gerne
einige tage vor den videos mehr von
hinter den kulissen erfahren wollt dann
folgt mir da gerne in meiner ins tor ist
übrigens auch richtig viel von der neuen
wohnung aber ich bin echt happy ich
dachte nicht dass ich schon so schnell
eine coole idee für gamer ab wie ich bin
der ich glaube dass ein kleines ding die
entwicklung der app ziemlich in den bann
wie seit mehreren monaten nichts mehr
wir haben noch sehr viel zu tun dutzende
pixelige grafiken zeichen der sp
programm ihren sound und musik erstellen
all das ist für mich neu und motiviert
mich ich habe jetzt diese felsen ich
habe mit diesen schulden himmel als
entwicklungen sie wollten auf diesem
felsen ist nun ein saftiges gras das dem
ganzen eine fröhliche stimmung verleiht
alles ist so platziert dass hat ewig
gedauert bis es einigermaßen getreue war
aber es ist schon wirklich wichtig damit
ein bisschen struktur trinken ist fünf
uhr morgens hieß es selbst wenn mir echt
schwer
ich hätte doch weiterzumachen weise
komme jetzt ist es glaube jetzt einfach
ins bett zu nehmen
nachts kann ich nicht einschlafen beim
essen bin ich unkonzentriert dieses
projekt hat mich komplett im griff und
hat mich ohne übertreibungen süchtig
gemacht aber die suchthilfe hoffentlich
dabei in dieser woche was heftiges über
einzustellen so sieht übrigens unsere
spieler aus ich hatte mir jetzt gerade
schon unseren ersten dino bis anhin war
einfach ein bisschen komisch aber nach
zwei drei tutorials habe ich den dreh
raus gehabt bald im grunde ist es
eigentlich das gleiche wie mit anderen
programmen die ich ja schon kennen wie
zum beispiel update ist
[Musik]
das ist so süß ich kann es nicht
beschreiben aber ich hoffe dem ding ja
ganz leben ein ass für sich so erfüllen
anerkennt bestimmt pinocchio und sein
vater schnitzel holzpuppe und dann
erweckte sie zum leben und genau so
fühle ich mich gerade die ich immer
einer klangwelt leben einhauchen konnte
sowie senat wollte ich mich jetzt nicht
für komplett verrückt als name für die
app habe ich mir nach langem überlegen
netscape ausgesucht und dieses kleine
logo gebastelt mit einigen tutorials
bringe ich mir die absoluten grundlagen
des programmierens mit sap in unity bei
unity ist übrigens das programm mit dem
ich hier arbeite immer wenn ich etwas
neues lernen gehe ich ähnlich vor ich
habe jetzt zum beispiel meine spielfigur
gezeichnet und will dass sie sich auf
knopfdruck bewegt da ich keinen plan
haben die das geht suche ich unity
player moment auf youtube und schaue mir
dazu ein video an
dieses video ist mir dann genau das zu
machen und ich setzte es in die tat um
und das wissen wird verinnerlicht
schnell komme ich danach natürlich
wieder an einem punkt wo ich nicht mehr
weiter weiß und die suche nach dem
nächsten onlinekurs der mir weiterhilft
und schon ein winziges stück
anspruchsvoller ist auf diese art und
weise entwickle ich nach und nach in
vielen verschiedenen kleinen punkten
wissen und fähigkeiten welche sich dann
miteinander vernetzen und zumindest
halbwegs flächendeckend werden
es lebt nämlich aus aber ich krieg auch
in taste und der bruder bewegt sich
einfach dass es will
das ist zu wenig ganz kurze ried ob das
was ich mache ist mega umfangreich und
ich finde jede einzelne facetten
übertrieben spannend und erfüllen und
das video könnte leicht über eine stunde
gehen ich habe vor kurzem mit dem
streamen auftritt angefangen und wäre es
da auch mal meine videos ausführlicher
begleiten deswegen nach diesem video
wenn ich da auch live an dieser app noch
weiter entwickeln also folgt mir gerne
auftritt schlink in der beschreibung
heute um 20 uhr wird live weitergemacht
und ihr könnt mit entscheiden aber
dieses videos nicht so ausführlich das
soll kurz und prägnant sein in diesem
sinne let's go
wir haben viel geschafft langsam wirds
richtig spannend der fortschritt war
allerdings an den ersten beiden tagen
viel krasser als jetzt an tag 3
die veränderungen im vordergrund die
sieben neben ganz deutlich aber diese
ganzen sachen im hintergrund dies eben
braucht bis so eine app flüssig läuft
sieben wir nehmen nicht so abwegig okay
was ist neu der spieler kann sich jetzt
bewegen springt uns drücken und das hat
einfach stunden gedauert bis es jetzt
genau so läuft wie ich es mir
vorgestellt habe dann verfolgt die
kamera den spieler dann habe ich
ursprünglich auch normale bilder benutzt
als plattform auf denen man rumspringen
kann bin aber jetzt auf eine sogenannte
teil pellet umgestiegen diese bausteine
die ich hier gewechselt hat kann man
jetzt in sämtlichen richtungen
zusammenstössen womit sich welten
umwelten leicht denken also wenn ich dir
einfach jedes mal neu zeichnen milka
viele bugfixes wie zum beispiel dass
hier der spieler nicht mehr kannte fest
stecken bleibt und das ist eigentlich
und das war das komplizierteste diese
random entlässt world generation so eine
position jetzt eigentlich aber die wird
immer weiter generiert unendlich ist
hast du natürlich geil ich habe das zum
teil von uns übernommen und verstehe
deswegen auch nur die sachen die ich auf
ihr gewissen muss und abändern muss aber
es macht endlich das was ich möchte und
das reicht mir auf jeden fall
wir stehen vor einem fundamentalen
probleme und zwar meinte die sophie dass
niemand lust und spaß dabei haben wird
diese knoten dinos kaputt zu machen und
da hatte kommt heute recht niemand will
diese die nuss geboten und da brauchen
wir ein komplett neues spielkonzept
ich hätte schon fast die süßen dinos aus
dem spiel gestrichen und sie durch busse
ersetzt aber dann durch einen zufall
okay was nach us währung in kometen die
man aufsammeln und dann von zehn stück
kann man sich ein cooler als kaufen oder
ein komet ist die perfekte bedrohung die
nur sein vom kometen bedroht okay das
ist logisch in der man verbrennen kann
erdbeben erdbeben werden man kann
verschiedene teams sammeln wir schon
zwei gemacht und wenn man sie nicht hat
dann kann man eben auf den reifen und
rum griffen und die haben dann alle
verschiedene eigenschaften dass er das
schafft ich grad von selbst beflügelt
von diesem gedankensprung schreibe ich
das konzept auf und es liest sich wie
folgt der spieler ist ein zeitreisender
höhlenmensch der die dinosaurier vom
aussterben retten will zusammen mit
seinem reiz dino versucht er vom
meteoriten lava und tiefen abgründen zu
entkommen dabei sammelt er dino eier um
sich neue niedliche die nuss mit anderen
eigenschaften freizuschalten bis er auch
den seltensten dino gesammelt und ihn
trainiert hat der vernichtung zu
entkommen durch das einsammeln seltener
kristalle kann er schicke accessoires
oder starke rüstung für sich und seine
dinosaurier kaufen als in app käufe gibt
es zum beispiel coole skins für die
dinos die man freischalten kann aber
keinen spiel vorteil bringen damit es
fair für alle bleibt zusätzlich hat der
spieler die möglichkeit durch das
ansehen von kurzen werbeclips ein
extraleben freizuschalten und seine
kristalle zu vermehren also ich bin das
konzert ist wirklich der hammer und ich
bin auch die militarisierung ist frei
und keine wegen der tradition
irgendwelchen schals zu kaufen
wie das in anderen apps oft einfach ist
aber wir haben trotzdem die möglichkeit
herauszufinden wie leicht sich mit einer
app geld verdienen ist aber das muss
natürlich auch noch alles programmiert
werden und das ist unfassbar viel marius
angeschrien meinte dass in einer woche
zu schaffen sei enorm ambitioniert
vielen dank übrigens alvarez so führt
als er mir bei einem bug geholfen hat
bei dem der spieler so unschön geruckelt
hat er hat mir in meinem letzten video
auch die grundlagen der musikproduktion
gezeigt weswegen ich den spiel
soundtrack natürlich selbst mache ich
schnappe mir trommel sound und ordnen
sie zu einem zugegeben sehr simplen beat
an der aber perfekt zur atmosphäre passt
[Musik]
aber habe ich nicht eigentlich gesagt
das soll kurz und prägnant sein los
geht's wir machen eine zeitreise und
überspringen 4 16 stunden arbeitstage
industrie auf die rechte seite des
bildschirms klicken sein man kann es
einfach richtig gut von spielen das ist
echt heftig wenn s hybrid alles nicht
mehr an die boxen bewogen haben kann ein
wird jetzt die app richtig flüssig
spielen also wäre es halt ne app die
nicht so gut gemacht hatte wie ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich schon hart
stolz drauf bin was ich häng ich cup
ohne vorkenntnisse ich hab mir natürlich
viel mehr sachen vorgenommen als ich
jetzt wirklich umgesetzt habe und dann
kann es endlich auch in den play sorgen
ok 12 profiliert sich ist es soweit
release erstellen
ein unerwarteter fehler eine unerwartete
fehler
nachdem ich gestern ohnehin von morgens
bis nachts gearbeitet habe habe ich
nochmal 15 stunden ohne schlaf weiter
gearbeitet bis 13 uhr mittags das war im
zeitraum der entwicklung von deines kate
aber eher die regel als die ausnahme
okay es ging es irgendjemand es die app
offiziell ich weiß gar nicht wieso ich
so viel energie aber ist 12 40 bin seit
sonstwas wach und ich bin
google braucht nun ticker sieben tage um
die app zu verifizieren dieses video
kommt allerdings in fünf tagen online
wenn google ihn nicht unerwartet schnell
ist war es das mit diesem experiment
doch das war erst die erste hürde nach
einer mütze schlaf widme ich mich dem
apple app store es klappt nicht aufgrund
eines fehlers werde ich bei apple auf
die blacklist gesetzt und kann mich
nicht mehr anmelden selbst zahlreiche
kontaktierte apple mitarbeiter können es
sich nicht erklären und empfehlen mir
einen neuen account zu erstellen
doch selbst nachdem ich erst zwei tage
lang mit einem anderen echten namen von
bekannten einer anderen handynummer oder
sogar einem anderen pc und einem anderen
netzwerk versuche wenn das jetzt
funktioniert es geht ja immer auch nicht
apple sperrt mich freitag einen tag vor
video upload und auch google in ein
letzter hoffnungsschimmer hat es noch
immer nicht meine app freigeschalten
also dass unmögliches passiert ist
überhaupt ich habe mich so gefreut wenn
wir jetzt in den play store geht findet
man jetzt deine skype und kann sich
jetzt an herunterladen
einen tag bevor das mit die online kommt
ihr spiel stand ist ja schon gespeichert
weil sie diese test epi case ja schon
getestet hat und ähnlich wird auch euer
geld und euer highscore gespeichert wenn
ich dann mal updates rausbringen und man
andere coole inhalte noch eben geld
kriegen kann das heißt man jetzt weiß
nicht es macht gesammelt könnt ihr euch
irgendwann überwunden ist kaufen also
das was der highschool geklagt man hat
einfach 480 da war kommt man ja ok auf
jeden fall mein rekord ist 479 wenn
jemand von euch den ernsthaft knackt
dann schickt mir davon gern villa
fenster können wenn ich mal gespannt
der erste gang knackt wird in der story
gestartet wie sophie spielt jetzt noch
weiter und nicht jetzt schon mal gleich
ein update bei der programmierung
das ziel
items und dinos bereitzustellen habe ich
ja da nicht geschafft genauso wenig wie
ich es geschafft habe die app zu
monetarisieren die app wird aber weiter
entwickelt zum beispiel heute 20 uhr
live auftritt und es wird einen zweiten
teil zu diesem video geben welches davon
handelt wie viel geld ich mit der app
verdiene und wie ich es bewerber auch
nicht nur im deutschsprachigen raum
sondern auch im englischsprachigen raum
oder meiner deutschen reichweite ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr die app
testet und mir eine ehrliche bewertung
da lässt auch wenn ich nicht alles
geschafft habe ich habe alles gegeben
und in dieser kurzen zeit wäre absolut
kein bisschen mehr drin gewesen
der link zur app und allem was noch in
zukunft geplant ist ist in der video
beschreibung dieser das erste video aus
unserer neuen wohnung wurde übrigens
unterstützt von mal im eigenen
schnittkurs damit lernt man ganz schnell
alles was man für schneiden von youtube
videos musik videos oder urlaubsvideos
braucht es ist kein komisches abo und er
hatte kurz und bündig auch auf
lebenszeit wenn ihr also jetzt auch was
neues lernen möchte oder einfach klasse
entscheiden werden der schnittkurs auf
den link dazu ist eine video
beschreibung wenn ihr wissen wollt
welches video nächste woche kommt laut
germania auf instagram vorbei da seht
ihr immer meinen stories einblicke was
gerade passiert und was ich mache und
keine einblicke in die videos schon weit
bevor die überhaupt online kommen wenn
ich auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
mit mir natürlich gerne wieder
[Musik]